parler en direct avec nous jean vincent
brisset directeur de recherche à
l'institut des relations internationales
et stratégiques iris spécialiste de la
chine et des questions stratégiques en
asie siens monsieur brice et merci à
d'être avec nous en direct alors pour
les etats unis c'est clair hong kong
n'est plus un territoire autonome
quelles seront les conséquences
alors les conséquences directement ça va
être un blocage d'un certain nombre de
relations et ça va être ce qui est le
plus pénalisant pour la chine un arrêt
des exemptions de taxes douanières de la
part de la des états unis tout ce qui
transite par hong kong parce que l'on
compte c'est une économie d'entrepôt on
y fabrique pas grand chose mais par
contre il ya également deux choses qui
transitent par hong kong qui sont
revendus par hong kong et qui rentrent
sur le territoire américain sont payer
de taxes douanières
alors les états unis offensif est
également sur la question des ouigours
la situation des vigoureux n'est pas un
nouvel on en parle depuis longtemps
est ce que les américains ne se servent
pas un peu de cette cause pour affronter
les chinois il est évident que
l'administration preuve sancerre s en
sert d'autant plus facilement que il est
extrêmement difficile pour les
démocrates qui sont ses principaux
opposants de dire que ça se passe bien
vis-à-vis des ouigours donc le démocrate
sont obligés d'entériner toutes les
décisions qui sont prises au nom de la
liberté
et ça les oblige à faire qu'à chaque
fois qu'on parle des ouïghours à chaque
fois qu'on parle de manifestations
démocratiques à hong kong parce qu'elles
sont vraies manifestations démocratiques
les démocrates sont obligés de suivre ce
que propose le presidents cup alors
clairement la guerre 1 chine etats unis
elle est plus vraiment économique
or la guerre je suis né gréverie est une
guerre économique parce que trump
fonctionne en termes de business 1 et
pas du tout de relations politiques
classiques y fonctionne comme ça en
bilatéral donc tout ce qui peut servir à
affaiblir l'adversaire et d'apprendre et
en particulier tout ce qui est
économique mais c'est surtout dans un
but économique et on utilise un petit
peu sûres
en plus pour forcer la main des
arguments des sur la démocratie sur les
droits de l'homme et autres alors la
donne et rempile est en coin
actuellement que toute la communauté
internationale ce rallye un peu dernier
sur la question de hong kong et sur la
question des ouïghours alors toute la
communauté internationale si jamais le
problème de trump le problème de trump
c'est de rallier déjà les états unis
derrière lui et à ce niveau là il a déjà
très largement gagné sur la conduite à
tenir vis-à-vis de la chine où il avait
gagné visa et ses acolytes à tenir
vis-à-vis de la corée du nord
maintenant au point de vue international
la haine de preuves est tellement forte
et non pas mal de milieux dirigeants que
il ya là qu'ils vont continuer à
soutenir la chine mais c'est difficile
de dire que les lois que la chine tente
d'imposer à hong kong sont des bonnes
lois et sont des lois respectable alors
il y a quelques jours le ministre
chinois des affaires étrangères
parlez-lui de guerre froide on en est
l'actuel montre les états unis et les
chinois c'est une guerre froide qui est
en train de se dessiner
alors on en est très très loin de ce qui
s'est passé à l'époque de la guerre
froide entre les étals et à la lune aux
soviétiques et l'occident mais on est à
l'heure actuelle dans quelque chose qui
se passe à des distances beaucoup plus
grande ya pas de frontière commune entre
l'occident et la chine
il ya simplement des liens qui sont
beaucoup plus des liens commerciaux
techniques et que des liens purement
territoriaux et éventuellement militaire
alors qu'est-ce qu'on attend maintenant
de la réaction de la chine après ces
nouvelles accusations des américains sur
la question de hong kong et sur la
question des ouigours un la chine
il faut aussi voir que d'à côté trump
est en campagne électorale et d'un autre
côté c'est inkling est à l'heure
actuelle sur la grande la grande fête
annuelle du parlement chinois
donc il a des problèmes d'autorité il a
des problèmes à l'intérieur de son pays
qu'on ne refuse souvent de joueurs et il
est obligé d'afficher une position de
grand leader mondial vis-à-vis de son
propre pays
donc la chine va être obligée sans doute
de prendre des mesures de rétorsion
mais vis-à-vis des etats-unis c'est
assez difficile en et mesures de
rétorsion parce que tout ce qui pourrait
être désiré dans
sans cela va à la fois difficile pour
l'économie chinoise et va surtout
conduire une partie de la population
chinoise celle qui est en train de
s'enrichir
celle qui vit plutôt bien à ne pas avoir
le droit aux produits aux produits
américains et pas avoir le droit à la
sortie vers l'extérieur et sont pourtant
des choses que cette place sociale
cette nouvelle bourgeoisie chinois
respire beaucoup alors pour paraître du
coronavirus à quel point cette crise
sanitaire va affaiblir les chinois alors
cette crise sanitaire maintenant je
crois que tout le monde est à peu près
d'accord
la chine a beaucoup tardé à réagir comme
elle aurait dû réagir et après avoir
tardé à réagir elle a réagi en un terme
de manière assez remarquable en
utilisant des méthodes ils sont
considérés comme totalement inacceptable
dans les pays occidentaux
elle essaie d'effacer l'image de sa
mauvaise réaction de départ en montrant
la bonne réaction par la suite elle
essaie aussi d'effacer cette image en
montrant qu'elle veut aider tous les
pays du monde à faire quelque chose
contre le corps d'un virus maintenant il
faut qu'elle aille au delà du discours
pour le moment il ya un certain nombre
d'ambassadeurs qui se permet des
discours extrêmement violent est assez
inhabituel à l'extérieur de leur pays
il faudra que la chine démontre autre
chose et démontrer qu'elles qu'elles
participent vraiment à la lutte du monde
contre le corps navires us jean vincent
brisset merci d'avoir été en direct avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes directeur
de recherche à l'iris spécialiste de la
chine était question stratégique de
l'asie si merci